hello rejects so we're gonna be doing a
review of the short film cargo but
before we do that the real rejects is
teaming up with inferno starring Tom
Hanks directed by Ron Howard the sequel
to The Da Vinci Code and angels and
demons based off the beloved novels by
Dan Brown they have a fact finding
puzzle game that we ourselves just
played called journey through hell in
the game you get to work through
different challenges and puzzles through
each of the nine circles of hell the
inferno if you will we just got done
playing through the first three rings
which are limbo lust and gluttony this
week though coming out it is greed rap
and heresy there's plenty of cash prizes
and even a chance to win a trip to Italy
the puzzles are live now so click that
link in the description box below and
see if you can help Robert Langdon
survive the nine circles of hell and
don't forget to check out Inferno in
theaters October the 28th that is a
Friday ladies and gentlemen be sure you
don't really engage with the game all
right there they're throwing at you some
cool information some maps and stuff you
might learn a little bit if you take
advantage of this now John for no reason
at all let's change our clothes
alright well let's uh let's watch the it
so check out the cargo let's get spooky
herd this is a zombie apocalypse video I
love apocalypses
[Applause]
oh cool stuff good shot
[Music]
[Music]
Judith
[Music]
Oh No
Oh is he just injured he was bit no he
knows
[Music]
smart baby
[Music]
three hours before determines
thank you what it smell is a good
message dude he was trying to get to a
birthday party the whole time
[Music]
[Music]
is it Harry NoZe nostrils really
important
you hang on top
now I can't cite babies in the back
[Music]
that baby's correct Oh No
Oh
we can't eat the baby
how does it Mar did not see this going
hard this dude playing a hand so you
know you can kill the kid okay that's
why yeah oh that's so smart the baby
though
[Music]
he manages to find time to hit the
ginger in the apocalypse
so sad
is that baby ass
babies all grown up now John
hahaha oh poor baby
she could never have a kid so this is
great
well done well done that's terrific John
and I have seen a lot of short films in
our today that was really well done yes
terrific
was a sort of credits roll so lujan like
to respect the credits everyone usually
leaves John his family taught me early
on it's important to stick around for
the credits and a lot of people spend
time at least you can do is read their
names which we did not do I still look
look present well time to review this
thing I want to start off by saying that
I've seen a lot of horrible zombie short
films like a lot I was at the Burbank
Film Festival recently you had to leave
early I stuck around for the last one
Dave's late
it was oh man oh and the sad part is is
the guy who like started in and wrote
and directed it was there he thought he
you know those filmmakers I think they
made a guess like you in terms of just
production quality was just really just
really soft zombie is the sort of
classic you know no budget you know
place to go it's empty landscape and you
know it's like the makeup what does it
usually cost you that much to play
together it's usually for makeup artists
usually simple to do is something like a
zombie makeup you get a little liquid
latex or some silicone and some corn
syrup and you're on your way I mean this
has to be one of the most unique zombie
films of any command I've ever seen like
I was really impressed by this it's
smart because it is it goes back to the
old craft of like showing not telling
you even though there's some stuff where
it's like oh my name is Rosie is on here
it writes down three hours you're like
okay it's three hours before returns
okay besides that though like it is sort
of like you're wondering what is he
doing exactly like why does he have the
flesh hanging on there and first it's
just like okay it seemed like a
convenient way to keep his baby on his
back that's also a clever way to make
you go okay so this way he can't eat the
baby and give this baby a chance of
surviving the the flesh in front of him
that way he can keep moving for like he
was a clever little trick it was it was
really clever it was interesting to
watch it play out and in the end the
baby finds a new finds new humans to
live with a chance of survival again
that was really great I'd love to see a
follow up see what actually lets you
follow more like they just
like 20 years later and this kids all
grown up or maybe a man years later this
is one of those short experiences I feel
like it's sort of perfect as what it is
you know it's not fair I don't know if I
would necessarily want to see this as a
whole
think franchise John I think for France
six movies full length feature I mean I
definitely want to see what these people
can do next this is a visually told the
story that unfolds in a really nice way
like it makes you ask little questions
and then it shows you the answers as
time goes on and knows how to move you
without throwing the emotional aspect in
its face like the father clearly has a
motivation he clearly has a goal you
also see the emotional try but it's not
like forced in there well yeah I mean
the emotion is in the style but it's
also just in the unfolding of that plot
when you figure out what he's doing
you're like oh man well you're using the
last moments of your life just to make
sure this kid has a chance like which is
it's a beautiful little story surprise a
sniper didn't see the baby on the back
of him though I'm a glad that guy shot
at the right angle because like that
baby is kind of behind it yeah he fell
on if he fell on his back you would have
crushed that baby that is the one like
you know lucky cinema part I assume they
shot this in Austria they just like it
looks gorgeous it look yeah I mean this
is obviously like the cinematography is
great that's funny that but that really
impressed me this was I find my are find
that we're talking more about the way
the story played out more than the
actual technical sides which normally
when I watch a cool short film I find
myself talking more about technicalities
an actual storytelling yeah and here
this is like a short little zombie story
and yet we managed to still walk away
with the characters and I haven't be
overloaded with like zombie this really
no zombie kills in here it takes a
zombie story but gives you a completely
different thing inside of it you know
it's we've seen zombie carnage a billion
times yeah so let's do something a
little bit new with this and find a new
way also to explore what a human might
do in this situation
you know and the team of people that
like found them I really like how they
don't like how dialogue I like how this
whole thing doesn't have very much
dialogue like is there any at all
there's no point really other than like
exposition or establishing the specific
details but I love it what a short film
is like let's just let it be open to
interpretation let just let it be like
let's just see
why the woman's stuck around and decided
kneel down next to the body and wait for
something to happen oh you know they're
checking it probably for just to see who
he might have been and if he's got any
useful supplies and then you know that
that cry it just the right time but yeah
I like when people make shorts without
dialogue it's just kind of a nice change
of pace it's easy in shorts to just
demonstrate style going kind of fact
what you yeah it's like it's easy to
just demonstrate style and this has a
lot of style but this also has a lot of
very human heart and and it does have an
idea yeah and it does have an emotional
core and so this is kind of a perfectly
rounded film to me it's like I cannot
wait to see what these people do next
and with more means let's come out 2013
2013 wow those long time ago it's 3 or 3
years ago actually in February 2013
they probably have something else out
I'm sure and the dad is smart yeah you
watch like fear of the walking dead
there are a lot of not smart characters
and a lot of Tommy this even goes to
sort of what we were talking about in a
one of our weekend of horror videos this
is the kind of thing that excites me
nowadays when when I'm watching you know
new or stuff like that is you know
horror that's mixed with a different
vibe and a different aura because I've
seen cool carnage a thousand times but I
don't see this a whole lot well I think
one thing that with like zombie stuff
has a late I mean I think of like not
just walking dead but even that
Schwarzenegger film Maggie they're
taking zombies like the zombie set up
the apocalyptic world but they're really
providing like an emotional depth to
this type of aura this type of tone yeah
which I really love I really respect
that because there was a time where it
was more about the horror and the haunt
yeah and you know I think back to like
George Romero days cuz of granite those
are some great films he made so it's
cool to see yeah like I don't know I was
really well kind of jealous like it's
simple it's beautiful at the same time
and it makes you remember you know the
beauty in a simple idea and that's the
thing that just me when I'm when I'm
thinking of things to write I would like
to get back to some of my favorite
things have come from that idea of going
most people would try to go crazy with
this yeah what's a simple story you can
tell in a kind of fantastical
environment they would try to go like
two hearts
with it and I thought this had a great
gun this is perfect the probe yes is
perfect it appropriately already it's
got the contains story and the contains
got the story again all that stuff to
back it up it's just on the channel I
mean I'm assuming from the Film Festival
Tropfest I'm gonna check out more of
their short films I gotta see what other
big winners they had there thank you to
the negative maiya show
nACCHO oh I know what that show is is
it's a show a bunch of freaks that's
mean know what I mean to call freaks I
saw the American Horror Story season
freak show and I believe the appropriate
terminology is freaks yes yeah
that's what I got yeah at a time I see
Siamese twins freaks they prefer to be
called conjoined twins and Hillbillies
prefer to be called sons of the soil but
no you never gonna he'll really refer to
be called Hicks yes they do / they do
political really Magnus respond well to
that I'm trying not to be a fan no Billy
they respond in hillbilly well alright
reject subscribe today become a reject
if you're not already a reject mean your
I gotta think of a cooler way to put
this in phrase John is facebook.com
slash blue mouse and the real rejects
what does he do there he is a social
media manager and like we said earlier
make sure to keep a look out from Brno
October 28th Friday and in the meantime
go on journey through hell calm and take
a journey through hell
mmm-hmm core so you can just have my
wife's cooking not good not good
that's painful experience to eat it you
don't appreciate what she does for you
know and I cheat on her oh yes you do
yes I do with the receptionist at my
office ah
and I joke about it with the boys at
work over cigars and then we stand naked
in the Country Club locker room and hit
each other with towels and pretend that
there's nothing going on between the two
of us while we play cricket while we
play cricket